Rob here with a GS news update Microsoft
has admitted that rise of the Tomb
Raider will not be an Xbox exclusive
forever it was announced during
Microsoft's event at Gamescom yesterday
that rise of the Tomb Raider would be an
Xbox exclusive for holiday 2015 angering
many fans of the series but the wording
of the announcement was misleading
causing many to assume the game would be
an Xbox exclusive title for ever coming
holiday 2015 exclusively to xbox Xbox
boss Phil Spencer has admitted that the
exclusivity deal won't last forever when
asked if there is a limited period of
time covered by the deal Spencer replied
yes the deal has a duration I didn't buy
it I don't own the franchise so the game
is still exclusive to Xbox platforms but
only during holiday 2015 sometime after
that it will come to other platforms
perhaps exclusive wasn't quite the right
word for this arrangement the release
date of the game is still unknown it is
coming to xbox one and on xbox 360 at
the end of 2015 and it can be assumed
that PlayStation 3 4 and pc will get the
game at some later date what's your
opinion of the whole situation do you
feel better now that xbox has admitted
that it won't be just theirs or do you
feel that they could have worded the
whole thing a little bit better leave
your comment in section below have a
great day see you later
you